hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the toilet chronicles the
game where you're trapped in a toilet
and stuck there it was subject to the
whims of the demons and the hellish
manifestations that they
subject you to while you're in the stall
it's a horror game set in the bathroom
rescue of board
q quits turns out i wasn't bored
but this game has
i'm sorry what this game is said that
[Music]
oh
god oh god
[Laughter]
[Music]
ah
so like i said this is a horror game set
while you're in a toilet you're in a
bathroom in a 2008 party
attempt number one
uh
what do you mean attempt number one
i lost my magic marker out of order it
said that every
f
it said that every single single thing
you do
will change the course
of your destiny
what is happening
oh
i get it
restroom is for your convenience
i'm not that stupid to try that again
oh i am you killed yourself now the
mysteries of this place will never be
solved
okay
so yeah this is uh oh it's fixed who
fixed it
oh
good god okay you got burned from the
exploded hand dryer
great trying again attempt number three
i'm not stupid enough to try that again
ah yep i tried it again you got burned
again who would have thought
i did i would have thought well
apparently the hand dryer means death
so let's try not to uh die
time number four
i haven't even made it to the toilet
do you live in a 3d world then you will
need some 3d trees this is not important
for the game don't scan that code
we care about our customers
would poop here again
actually lixian double check that that
code is not a virus and if you get a
virus you are protecting the other
people from getting a virus and if it is
a virus repair your computer after the
virus has infected and deleted all your
files then re-record this video because
clearly this video would have been
deleted and then make it all in my style
and then blur out that qr code if it's a
virus but if it's not a virus
it's all good have you seen this man
this man is a war criminal
okay
nothing
fascinating
hello
hello
hello hello
looks like someone is in there does it
someone is destroying a toilet
it's getting darker
ah
[Music]
interesting
chapter one hand what do you mean hand
oh god what
proceed to cry why
[Music]
toilet paper
[Music]
i think i can just leave
[Music]
you left the restroom without destroying
a toilet
oh was i supposed to you left the
restroom with no answers zero of twelve
what does that even mean
all right whatever
i'm going for it
i didn't lock it
hey buddy any chance you got some um
toilet paper because this [ __ ] is empty
over here partner yeah buddy i got you
thanks
you're welcome
[Music]
too bad i can't read
why why don't leave why not leave i'm
leaving
i'm leaving immediately
i'm leaving
i'm leaving oh
make him leave what do you mean
what do you mean
make him leave
what do you mean
what do you mean make him leave
oh fixed i don't know what do you mean
make him leave
[Music]
can i throw things
don't show them wet it
don't show who
uh
what you can jump i can
[Music]
i'm gonna wet it
chapter two vent
oh
i don't know why it's sticking why is it
ticking
oh i don't know anything
this is odd yeah a little bit
what if i
[Music]
oh
okay
hold on
oh god
there you go
i think it's out of pictures okay well
this is uh fascinating
something for you why would i have
something whoa
uh
kill him how the cake is a lie well
that's a cool reference from a while ago
right click to pull the ring
okay and now what
you killed yourself now the mystery
well i guess i
should have realized that yeah okay
fascinating what
sorry for the last time now it is fixed
oh
it wasn't fixed what if i hit it and run
away
oh
[Music]
i have this now
does this help
interesting
yep i got you buddy
um
not an ending you're not supposed to be
here what do you mean
what did i do
what did i do
what did i do how did i do that negative
one what do you mean oh god oh god oh
god
why was it so dark
hey buddy any chance you got some um
toilet paper oh yeah [ __ ] is empty over
here oh yeah buddy i got you what
hello oh yeah i got you buddy
oh yeah i got you buddy
oh
what
what what do you mean
what wall
what wall
what wall
which wall this wall
oh
it didn't work
just pretend that there is a hole and
enter the void
no joker dancing i couldn't come up with
other rules but really wanted to add
that joker meme so
for yellow doors only oh
i don't know what the hell [ __ ] you
okay all right okay
okay all right fine
okay all right i get it i get it i get
it give me that give me that
give me that
blow up the door for some reason
take this go don't slip on the banana
i can't take that
and that's fine the movie this poster
joke was stolen from pound cake shout
out to him the movie too are you dumb on
purpose this poster joker
[ __ ] you the prequel to the movie
[ __ ] you excuse me the sequel to the
prequel to the movie
okay fine
some kind of code staff only
can't go in
uh-oh
okay i expected pink walls did you
take
take another
scary taste
this game is incredible
yeah i forgot this was a party oh hey
okay nine the worst toilet in scotland
great ah
interesting
i see
oh come on
oh my god i don't even have time for my
brain to process any anything in this
game before i suddenly
throw in another curveball i love it but
also what the hell is happening
i haven't destroyed a toilet yet you're
goddamn right i haven't
you're goddamn right
oh wow what about okay so there's a nine
right so green nine is that
that
check
what
oh
okay
oh no
ah damn it
i tried to grab the note and it just did
that but whatever it's fine i really
don't know what i was expecting when i
loaded up this game i really didn't i
thought you know i thought it was gonna
be a slightly silly horror game about a
toilet i've played some things like that
before i think i've actually played a
toilet horror game exactly like that
before so i don't know what i was
expecting but it wasn't this
give me that
all right i'm gonna see if i can do
something about this
can i do this
is there any way that i can get this out
of there
hey do you know what's going on about
all this
well it's not chapter one anymore
honestly all i've got is green nine and
then red
all of these numbers
which doesn't help at all and then this
is basically nothing
oh god i destroyed a toilet
isn't that what the objective was didn't
it say
wait something says do not destroy
toilets but it didn't say don't destroy
toilets somehow there was another
grenade in there
so i'm thinking that somehow
yes
there must be a way
to get this
hope
yes no
yes
no in case of emergency for yellow doors
only okay so is there a yellow door
anywhere where would be a yellow door
wait what do you have
[Music]
oh no
oh no
okay so there's got to be something else
to do here unless there's something else
i can blow up i don't see any other
numbers right
what is this
take
take what
take what
take care of him
who who what
private
pile was here
you can't peek at other stalls not from
this angle
i can't be stopped
i'm being stopped
oh
no
oh god
[Music]
oh my god you got crushed by a tentacle
now the mystery scissors will never be
solved okay
okay maybe i should understand that i
can't peak it from this angle
[Music]
but what if i do oh i understand
i understand you're permanently banned
from this restroom i don't think i am
i don't think i am
oh
ooh
numbers
numbers five pink five
what
what
what the hell
holy [ __ ] that's terrifying
what
well that was terrifying what was that
about
it doesn't seem like there's anything
else i can do here cause not doing the
thing with that camera anymore
and i don't know why
okay i must be doing something wrong i
think i went to an
antithesis of what i
oh i should have grabbed the tentacle or
the the
the grenade i probably just took too
long i probably just took way too long
next step i'm gonna do is i'm gonna sit
in that stall and i'm just gonna wait
this may be a 10 15. it's not that bad
don't worry about it oh man got a poop
better lock the door
we're gonna play this nice and patient
when he says don't leave i ain't gonna
leave there's no way i'm gonna leave i
don't need to leave i would never leave
everything i do has an impact on what
i'm doing and where i'm doing it which
is to say
hey buddy
you got it buddy
[Music]
well i'm not leaving then i'm just gonna
stay right here
[Music]
really nothing it's been like 15 minutes
just sitting here with my pants down
doing absolutely dick diddly
nothing
oh really
oh
well hi oh god no
i thought something would happen if you
stayed in the toilet but apparently not
okay so i gotta get these i gotta get
these other endings the mystery this
place shall be solved and it's not to do
with waiting in that stall but there is
a time limit apparently and i'm pretty
sure that it has nothing to do with
giving that guy any kind of toilet paper
but i am curious as to just
why things are different now than they
were i mean i know things are different
every time you you get some differences
here and there but i just want to know
i just want to know what's up with the
camera where'd the camera go how do i
get the axe i don't see any yellow doors
there's a way to get that accent i'm
gonna get it
make him leave aha there we go don't
show it
[Music]
come on
okay so now it's happening
don't show them huh
oh oh
oh two blue two blue two blue two
oh
oh
ah i mean i already experienced all this
but now i'm doing it actually in order
someone
is you know i do
you killed your partner oh my partner my
partner what do you mean my partner i
didn't know that i had a partner so all
that was for nothing because now i know
that i can get ahead
oh that's for naught oh whoa
i don't need to do any of that
oh
oops i don't know the cue to make it
look at you
interesting
wait a minute
wait a minute
what can i see through this
this might be a puzzle ah the red ah of
course
oh
my god
yes
eight okay red eight i've got four of
the numbers baby okay
so i got
blue two
pink five
this nine
this is eight
almost there
so
i think that sign must say
take
it to him
take something to him i'm not sure what
but maybe maybe this
there's got to be something else
oh no i'm running out of time
running out of time oh no
no no no
no
oh [ __ ] okay grenade time
oh god give me give me give it take this
[Music]
oh
my god i killed it
oh my god i killed it
holy [ __ ]
no not that what else could i take to
him
that no
that no
can no take
sa to him
whoa where am i oh god
whoa whoa that got dark why did that get
so dark i have no idea
that was weird
okay
one one one what is one one what would
be one
one
one of those one
oh what what
how wha what how
[Music]
how did that not work before
for yellow doors only
oh
hello
private pile was here
right click to get gnomed i don't know
if i wanna
oh
oh
come on
all right but i've got most of the
numbers do that again i'll do it again
look i'll die in any number of times i'm
ready
how did this not open before um uh
i must not have pressed the right button
but what do i do with a gnome okay what
do i do with a gnome right
come on
what
what
what
what
the hell
okay whatever take care of him what does
that even mean take care of him as in
kill him it's pretty much the only thing
i really know how to do
nope
hmm
please don't do that again
why
no
please don't do that again why
damn what are you gonna do
stop no
well you didn't throw it away
still got it in there
stop
oh
you pissed off your neighbor he crushed
your pelvis well that seems like an
inappropriate response i'm so confused
as to what i do with the gnome orange
six
it was in the loading screen all along
orange six
the other number is one it was in the
loading screen
the whole time
[Music]
it's blue two orange six
pink five green nine yellow must be one
and red is eight
oh my god
holy [ __ ]
did i do
did i do
oh what
hello
party break
i'm back at the party i forgot i was at
a party and that's all you're back at
the party
okay
they don't know i'm disappointed
sorry if you didn't get all the answers
but at least it was fun huh
what
oh and i i think i owe you one more
ending here
you're back at the party was it all a
dream what do you mean how do i know if
i've gotten all the endings
hello you can walk around if you want
and then just press q when you're bored
what if i'm never bored what if i know
that there's another ending here
just press this guy's a blackboard this
guy's crazy he's blanking
you're right
you're absolutely right
just press q when you're bored
fine
[Music]
but i didn't solve the mystery of the
bathroom
i didn't solve the mystery of the
bathroom there's something going on in
that toilet stall that i don't know
about
what is going on in my partner's strand
of part one is there's is there any way
to say see how many
is there any way to see how many
endings i got i think i'm missing ending
12.
i don't think i got that
i'm pretty sure i didn't get it
but what do i know
maybe it's at the bottom of the trash
can
what
i belong in the trash no you don't
you're a beautiful butterfly
and maybe that's a metaphor for this
world
you
oh
i understand
well anyway i think that's all for now i
don't know how to get the last mythical
12th ending but if you guys can figure
it out then you're better than me i'll
officially give you the you're better
than me award and you'll be better than
me
and then many subscribers will rain down
upon your youtube channel i think that's
how it works so thank you everybody so
much for watching if you ever find
yourself in a bathroom trapped with many
things that kill you and no reflection
in the mirror you might be a vampire you
might be dead or you might be in hell
any one of the three
thank you again for watching check out
more games and crazy random [ __ ]
that i've done in the past on my channel
pick a random video i wish there was a
random button for my channel recommend
in the comments completely random video
pick it random and just recommend that
one okay and then follow that train of
thought thank you and as always we'll
see you
in the next video
bye
[Music]